okay I'm here you know where do you with
I'm in Tribeca and uh and so I part I
looked at near City Hall
oh did you oh cool yes that's right
there huh um Morton raised in LA my
whole life New York thank you very much
bye you know I'm so happy to be here and
have my folks here this week is really
great so they're in from LA yeah they
came in for the week day so you know
we're just tourists week this is it's
after the rain yesterday yeah and New
York is like Vegas fruit smart people so
it's a good like that it's it's it's all
night for people like my folks you'd
come in here and every museum they
possibly want everybody you know it's
just they just have a blast
mm-hmm but for them it's like Vegas -
it's like they can be here for like five
or six days and they're just spent a few
sidecars yeah the Ritz Carlton but she
might be the martini generation yeah
that's really yeah